why don't you just pull up the first
video of the lady who runs a
restaurant in california sherman oaks
california not too far from an
hour away from me i'm 15 minutes away
from you sherman oaks california
who this happened to her and
you're gonna feel i mean this video on
twitter has already gotten nine million
views
her gofundme right now what is her
gofundme ad right now
has it crossed two hundred thousand
dollars i think it'll go fine yesterday
it was uh yeah when we did the video
yesterday it was 107.
let's see where it's at now uh a second
one there you go
164. okay good for she's the one in the
middle
and here's what happened to her um
play the video take a look at this folks
she runs a sushi spot so this is my
place the pineapple hill grill and
saloon
if you go to my page you can see all the
work i did for outdoor dining
for tables being seven feet apart and i
come in today
because i'm organizing a protest and i
came in to get
stuff for that and i walk
into my parking lot and obviously
mayor garcetti has approved
[Music]
this adam have you seen this i have
nothing okay this is good
tom you've seen this okay watch this
this being set up for this
being set up for for a movie company
a movie movie movie
but watch watch what happens i'm losing
everything everything i own
is being taken away from me and they set
up a movie company
right next to my outdoor patio which is
right over here
how do you justify it and people wonder
why i'm protesting
and why i have had enough
they have not given us money and they
have shut us down we cannot survive my
staff cannot survive
look at this
look how far apart they are tell me that
this
is dangerous 20 yards yeah but right
next to me
as a slap in my face
that's safe this is safe
50 feet away
this is dangerous mayor garcetti and
gavin newsom is responsible
for every single person that doesn't
have unemployment
that does not have a job and all the
businesses that are going under
and we need your help we need somebody
to do something about this
you know that's more powerful than if
they had scripted it oh
listen there is nothing you feel a pain
when i first saw that i was so mad
i mean i could not believe what i was
watching and hearing i could not believe
it and it brought it all to life
do you know how much she spent
renovating her deck to get it ready
eighty thousand dollars eighty grand she
paid
to renovate that i know so many stories
like that garcetti is such
a prick i just can't even believe it
when you heard his
reaction to this my heart goes out to
her and
that's all he said no thoughts no offer
to assist them
in any way it's it's the beginning
uh they they are trying to legislate fun
out of people's lives i really believe
that i think they have
chosen the restaurant industry to
demolish it for some reason
in some of these states in california
for sure i mean it's unbelievable
manhattan beach you know we were talking
about that last week
these guys are smart because you know
the same thing you can't have outdoor
dining there in every restaurant there's
a lot of great restaurants there and
they all have outdoor dining
they've designated all their outdoor
decks as public parks
so now you can get your take out and go
sit out there so they found a little
loophole
and i'm sure city hall's ticked off
about it i'm sure ellie county's not
happy about it but
man she's a star now she was on fox
yesterday she was as compelling on neil
cavuto's show yesterday she was there
i mean she is going to be the face of
this movement from coast to coast
michigan watch what's happening there
new york same thing it's uh it's just
the beginning of what's going on
so three quick things how do you number
one how do you not feel for that lady
i mean i don't care whether you're where
you stand politically
mass no mask left right up down
the lady's pouring her heart out right
there if you don't feel for her like
you're missing something going on in
your life so
yeah i got the chills just watching her
that's number one number two
the outdoor dining thing really
california is that absurd that they're
shutting down
outdoor dining like we've we all had
lunch we we were in manhattan beach
there's a big difference between indoor
dining and social distancing and all
that and outdoor dining i mean
that i've said the same thing
continuously i don't understand why
they're shutting down outdoor
restaurants like hers especially when
she set up
um a specific area for people to eat and
i mean the hypocrisy of setting up a
movie company
i mean you couldn't again couldn't have
scripted that any better and then here's
i guess my third point
you said that the mayor responded
it's on you buddy it's on you to make a
move now after seeing that that is a
tangible example
are you just going to sort of be like oh
my heart goes out to you and give the
standard quote
are you actually going to say something
to that specific situation because
there's a case example
of how you are messing up buddy i'm sure
there's a million different case
examples but that is now live in effect
you ever been to a funeral you ever been
to a funeral where
a person uh uh you know you go to
funerals and then there's funerals what
i mean by that is you go to funerals but
everybody's very amicable
and it was kind of like yeah hey you
know what sorry man this i'm sorry hey
you know all this other stuff
you ever go to a funeral where somebody
is crying and you
fully feel the pain with zero
acting no drama you ever been you
brought up a store like that uh last
week
yeah i mean you go to funerals like this
that's what happened that's a that's her
funeral right there
that's the small businesses funeral you
just saw that but she's slapping the
face
of course it's a slap in the face
because it was caused by something that
could have been prevented that's the
stuff that's annoying
that's when politics gets in and gets
dirty right that's when somebody like
that takes a hit
but by the way you're what people don't
realize is
you know you can only go so far doing
this we're going to keep showing this
stuff every time a video like this comes
up we're going to show it and we should
how much money does she raise
200 grand i think something 160 thousand
dollars right is that a lot of money
for her yeah yeah in general okay check
this out that's after 9.1 million views
she only raised 164 000 so that means
you need to rate you need to have a
video go viral like this to be able to
raise that kind of money
how about the rest of the people that
don't get this kind of exposure how
about the rest of the people that don't
have a video like that that gets picked
up and goes on tv how about the rest of
the how about those guys
how about the people that don't have a
platform and don't go communicate and
they don't get picked up by anybody how
about them yeah nobody talks about them
they do you think they're going to be
able to raise 200
000 100 no they're just having to shut
down now she's going to make it
she's going to be okay because 80
thousand dollars she spent on the deck
she's getting that back
and more and she can shut down for a
couple months and pay some of her
workers
and say guys let's just kick back she'll
be known as the
yeah i'm gonna throw this out there
right now why don't valuetainment why
don't we do a telethon like they do
after a big disaster after a hurricane
we should do a telethon
for the restaurant industry we could
raise them tens and tens of millions i
think that's a great idea i would
actually be very open to that for
getting but
we would need to collect the stories i'd
want to get people from across i'd love
to be able to do something like that
because
for me my concern isn't her she's fine
she's officially fine
she's officially going to be going to be
known as what the restaurant
so you're going to go eat there
intentionally just to do what i want to
support your business
right but the rest of them are the ones
that are going to take a massive hit
that's not going to change why is it
that the restaurant industry you said
that you thought that the restaurant
industry was single-handedly
being singled out what is it about they
have to answer that because they have
singled it out and i'll tell you what
there's a couple tipping points coming
up
wednesday there's a strong powerful
group of restaurant owners in la i mean
it's a great restaurant city and these
guys are ticked off
so they went to l.a county and the judge
was told the county that by wednesday
you have to come back here
and prove that there's contact tracing
that this is dangerous that you actually
have the data to prove that outdoor
dining is spreading covet so wednesday
is the day to watch
because if they can't do that the judge
might just open up the outdoor dining
for everybody
here's the other thing i say it's going
to lead to violence
look what's happening in michigan the
way whitmer is shutting down restaurants
and everything right there those people
don't play out there i mean they have
militias remember they almost tried to
abduct the governor and they had the
kids to kill her it's going to
do it thomas let's do it let's do it
let's kidnap right when you see that
pain
on her face multiply that by probably a
million people around the country that
work in the restaurant industry
she literally said on fox yesterday she
had two employees
family members that or knew two people
that committed suicide that killed
themselves
since this began someone is homeless
because of this and this is just in her
little small circle
and they don't give a damn about it
which is just disgusting
you said a million people that work in a
restaurant industry it's not a million
people you know what the number is more
than that it's 30 million people
it's it's not a small number 10 percent
of americans work in the service
industry
ten percent of americans work in the
service industry check out bars
everything you're talking about 15 to 30
million they say as high as 50 million
at one point have contributed towards
that industry like we've all worked
in that industry i've worked in this you
worked in the industry before you know
pat the other thing too is it's not like
these restaurant owners they tried to do
with that guy in staten island
you know he called his bar an autonomous
zone and tried to keep it open the city
went there he raised 80 grand
he did he raised some money too but
they're playing with fire because
they're all dictated by licenses
liquor licenses right and things like
that food and beverage licenses
the state can shut them down so easy so
it's not like they can just
this is very important for you to repeat
one more time folks pay very close
attention what time just said right
there say say what you just said one
more time right because if they want to
protest and say screw you government
we're just going to open our doors and
we don't care the state can just shut
them down because they all have liquor
licenses right
they have licenses to serve food to have
outdoor dining area so the state has
them
their doors stay open contingent on the
licensing
being uh they'd yank them in a second
they pull them right away
but something something to add you know
we've talked about this recovery and
obviously the stock market has bounced
back and then some
this is the v shaped is it the k shape
what kind of u-shape is the l-shape
this is a clear indication of this
k-shaped economy where the rich get
richer
and people that work in the insurance
business or the financial services
business
or anything where you could work from
home you'll be okay
you can work from home but anything that
you need to get out of your house you
can't yeah
and work in the service space industry
whether it's restaurants bars clubs
all that cruise ships anything travel
related hospitality that's the
you know the bottom half of the k-shaped
economy and those people are struggling
right now and that's why
congress needs to frickin act and get
their act together and pass this
trillion-dollar bill that's not going to
solve every problem think about these
people man
they also live in california where rent
is high taxes are high it's
it's a desperate it's crazy the two
places that are taking the biggest hit
is new york and california
those are the two places that are cost
of living is you know out of this world
you know i lived there for a long time
you know what it is to live in
california it's not cheap living over
there it's very expensive to be living
over there